hey guys justin here with a gamespot
news update recently the titanfall xbox
one bundle has been selling for four
hundred fifty dollars but the deal has
gotten even better with an online deal
at target which is bundling in one year
of xbox live gold this special price
also applies to the 425 xbox one bundle
and when you factor in the normal $60
asking price for Xbox Live plus the cost
of one of those games that brings the
Xbox ones cost down to three hundred
ninety dollars target is selling the
xbox one bundle for the standard five
hundred dollars in store so you want to
shop online for this deal in other deals
news best buy is currently offering xbox
one controllers for ten dollars off and
target is running a buy two get one free
game promotion this week for all
platforms which includes thousands of
titles including call of duty ghosts
battlefield 4 and NBA 2k14 among others
microsoft hasn't announced an official
price cut although they continue to sell
the titanfall Xbox one bundle through
their own website for four hundred fifty
dollars if you're looking to pick up one
of these Xbox one bundles you might want
to jump on that because we're unsure
exactly how long this deal is going to
last and for all your other xbox one and
deal related news be sure to stay tuned
to gamespot com